ass it's lovely to see you here today at
collective a and you have you been
enjoying it it's been brilliant you know
it's great to see everyone out here
today
now you've been really busy since we
last saw you at track here and told
premier haven't you tell us a little bit
about what you've been doing well are we
when I tossed rally oh we shot San
Andres and I was three months in
Australia and then we went and spent
like two or three weeks in San Francisco
as well which was amazing it was a great
film process and you know it was great
working with Dwayne and Alexandra and
Carla and they're all really helpful in
the process we went in dead about two
weeks of diving training and stuff like
that and they sort of helped us and told
us what would be going on we did a lot
of rehearsals whether the stunt men were
all brilliant on them as well so it was
fine really
but I was a little bit scary before we
started and what was the kind of
favorite moment you had while you were
filming either a scene or a memory I
think it was when the tsunami hurts and
all the water sort of rushed in you know
because we got to do a lot of our own
stunts and that was definitely fun you
know on the diving training we've done a
lot of practice with stuff like that so
it was brilliant Jeff and you hooked
some new projects coming up as well
haven't you yeah well we have to finish
a phone call Cubana two strings which is
an animation by Laker and that's with
Matthew McConaughey and Charlize Theron
and then we've got a few projects lined
up for the summer as well but we can't
really talk about that and of course
people are always wondering are we gonna
get to see Rick on again on Game of
Thrones cuz you know it's been a little
while has it I can't really say anything
about the character and about me
returning do you kind of miss the kind
of times and you're in in seasons 1 2 3
yeah well definitely I'll always miss it
you know and um but we've been very busy
with other work as well in your kind of
mind what do you think Rick on an Oscar
and shaggy-dog have been up to all this
time I'm not sure you know you know they
could have been off I think the books
follow cannibal Island called skagos and
but you never know what they're gonna
write and of course I mean we've seen
that bran is these amazing walking
abilities so would you like to have that
do you think you know Rick on could have
that what would you like to do if that
were the case well hopefully you know
and hopefully I could control shaggy-dog
or something like that and the show here
you know I actually have to catch up on
- episode 2 so I've only just started
watching it so yeah I'm gonna have to
catch off a lot more it's gonna be
talking to you enjoy the rest of the day
we look forward to seeing you in lots
more things in future thanks thank you
boy
you